I have temporary lip fillers it's just  an insecurity of mine and it's what I  wanted to do oh how times have changed  cuz kylie jenner's getting back to the  basics I don't feel any different fans  noticed a big difference in the lip cake  creators face when she posted this  Instagram pic with her pal Stassi to  celebrate eight years of friendship  commenters pointed out how Kylie had  more natural looking lips and wrote she  looks like the old Kylie which was spot  on because the new mom revealed she got  rid of all her fillers yes kylie is  proudly flaunting her old pouch and  natural hair since giving birth to  daughter stormy it seems the 20-year old  reality star is all about embracing her  authentic self and we are loving the  real her I love it  [Music]